bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you today i have
uh most of if not all of the synthesis
team here
uh i've invested in this business
because i fundamentally believe in what
they are doing
and i wanted them to come on and really
talk about uh the problem with education
in america today and then what they've
built to start solving this
and so uh i will have them each
introduce themselves
as they start to talk but maybe we'll
start with josh
if you can kind of introduce yourself a
little bit and then give us some
background in terms of
your involvement with astra and what
that is and kind of how you got into
wanting to build an education company
sure yeah um 2014 elon
musk approached me to start a school for
his kids and a few others at spacex so
that school became
ad astra school and i ran that school
for six years and
that school spun off and is now
astranova so i'm the
executive director and founder of that
school and then synthesis was basically
like the class that i taught at
astra and continued to teach at
astronoma which was like collaborative
problem solving like bringing kids
together to like work through difficult
problems and sort of like learn those
tough lessons along the way
so uh so yeah so then i you know met
chris
and uh when i was doing a project at uh
with with class
dojo trying to bring like good questions
to kids around the world
and uh we just started talking about
like what else could be scaled
through at astra and that became that
became synthesis
very cool and then chrisman maybe you
can uh introduce yourself and then
explain when you first saw
uh at astra and the course that our
class
has now become uh synthesis kind of what
did you see why did it stick out to you
and why do you want to go work on it
yeah yeah so my name's chrisman frank
i'm the
co-founder and ceo um before
before starting synthesis with josh i
was i was a class dojo as you mentioned
which is uh
this massive messaging app for uh
k through five teachers and families got
51 million
users worldwide i was the first engineer
there and uh
my my kind of uh thing i was really
excited about was using that network to
distribute
better ideas right like right now you
have to if you want to get good ideas
into classrooms
you need to go sell them school by
school principal by principal or
district by district and it's just a
terrible process and
you know we can all kind of see the
results in the schools so
uh the ceo there and i uh we went down
to
visit at astra and actually by this
point i was kind of i was kind of burned
out on seeing schools i felt like i'd
kind of seen everything i'd seen all the
fancy schools in the bay area and like a
lot of other places in the country
i've seen top public schools top private
schools and
you know honestly like just nothing was
uh nothing was particularly innovative
or impressive
so you know going down to visit elon
school you know it was
just what i knew it was the time i was
just like not expecting much
um but i think we met josh for dinner
like the night before
and he josh was like so intense like we
had dinner from like
six to like 6 28 and then he was like
off like to get back to work
and i was like that was like my first
inkling like all right this this might
be a little different
um and so yeah we went to the school and
it was uh it was just
unlike anything i'd ever seen like it
you know blew me away it's kind of like
you know maybe what people would imagine
from like a project that elon's involved
with like everything
was uh everything was different and uh
mine was just like spinning from
everything i saw and when i was touring
there
and then the moment that really stuck
with me was we were out for like recess
lunch and i was just hanging out with
some of the teachers
and uh and there are these kids that
were like they were still inside and
they were around a table
just like shouting at each other but
shouting these like really complex
sounding arguments
and i was like what what is going on in
there and one of the teachers was like
oh yeah that's uh
it's it's a synthesis week like you know
the kids get pretty obsessed with
synthesis
like what what is this because this
sounds they sound like they're having
the kind of conversations that we have
at work like in a tech startup like what
is going on here and she kind of
explained you know it's like these games
and they're
they're on team so they're collaborating
within their team but then they're
competing against the other teams and
the kids just like
go nuts and they get really engaged with
this and
you know pretty much from that moment
like i was hooked like i was just like i
need
my son was only two at the time but i
was like i need him to do this because i
think if he
gets out in the world and he comes up
against people that are trained this way
like he doesn't stand a chance so how do
i get him in here
and josh like you know you can get a job
as a rocket engineer at spacex and then
you've got like you know maybe a one in
100 chance of getting your kid
in here um and then that was kind of
like all my options at the time
so we sort of over the next couple years
you know just uh josh and i got to be
friends and just talked a bunch more
worked on some stuff at class dojo
and uh eventually you know decided the
time was right and it was uh
the right thing to do to try and open
this up and get it to you know
accessible to more people for sure
before we get to ana and kind of the
start of synthesis josh explain a little
bit more about
what was the impetus for elon to want to
start a school
um and what was the thought process as
you started it with him were there
certain mandates or directives how did
you come up with the curriculum
uh what were the types of teachers that
you put into that school to kind of make
it different or fit the need that
elon and yourself had identified
sure i mean i think just most simply he
wanted a better school for his kids
you know i think it was just really that
and
you know for a pair regardless what type
of school your kids are going to if you
feel like your kids aren't being served
i mean not
many people have the ability to just
like ask them when they want to start a
school and for me it was like a dream
come true
i was like well yeah of course right he
invited me to come to spacex and was
like you know have you ever been here
before and i was like well
no like sorry let me just let me walk
you around and you know i
tried not to ask a stupid question
although like i don't know anything
about rockets
and uh we've sat down it's basically
like what do you think about the school
that they're at and
i told him what i thought and he's like
you know what about what do you think
about just like starting
like starting you know our own school i
was like yeah like where do i sign up
basically
so he said you know why don't you take
some time to think about it and then
like at four in the morning i wrote an
email i was like all right i'm in like
totally ready to go this is like what
needs to happen
and uh and i didn't hear from him for
like three months
maybe two or three months like i think
it was like maybe mid-november and i
didn't hear back until like
mid-january so in that amount of time
i'd kind of convinced myself that i had
like hallucinated the whole thing and
you know um you know kind of like an
opportunity missed
and then you know i was like oh you know
bro hey i got super busy
just uh yeah like let's definitely do
this i'll you know let's figure out like
the next steps
so really in terms of like guidance it
was just like make it great you know
like first principles approach like what
are the things that are going to be most
uh like meaningful to kids what kind of
experiences do they need to have
and then how can we you know like just
like we're not trying to get accredited
we're not trying to like build a program
that you know
can really be scaled at the time it was
just like make this a really great
experience for the kids that are part of
it
and then for me it was always i mean i
did teach for america
uh so i taught in low-income public
schools for my my first four years of
education
and you know public schools i mean
there's the challenges the public
schools face are
are like are pretty unbelievable right
and whether or not the schools are as
good as they
can be i think we always say like no
they're not but but my
harshest criticism was actually for like
the private schools
because those schools are not needing to
follow the mandates of the state or
having to sort of make all these
compromises at scale like
these schools are these like lush
beautiful campuses with like largely
affluent kids who are not
you know i don't know the experiences
they're having are like not that
interesting like they're just their
classes aren't that fascinating like the
challenges problems are working on
aren't that compelling so for me it was
like well how could i design really
engaging
challenging problems and give those to
students at a really young age
and then allow them to make the mistakes
they're inevitably going to make like
that's sort of the purpose of school
like kids that are roughly the same age
who are like learning these tough
lessons but it felt like to me that
you can't learn lessons if you're doing
worksheets you can't learn lessons if
you're doing like
static unchanging stuff so
synthesis started really as like kind of
like ethical quandary so
i i mean ethical just like quandaries
really so
i don't know like so here's the
department of veterans affairs
here's their budget here are the
different ways that you could spend that
money like how would you allocate
the money and like make a justification
for why just like simple stuff like that
and then you know building like
simulations basically where you could
like look at the effects of
gerrymandering or the effects of
redlining
or you know you could have you know like
figure out like how nasa should allocate
its budget so it started in that sort of
way and conundrums this thing with class
dojo was more of like an outgrowth of
those
the choices between seemingly equivalent
options and then synthesis
evolved to be more like games basically
like experiences that were like really
well designed
that provoked conflict between the teams
but they're all working towards
collaborative goals as well so
so that's kind of like where i started
going as i was leading the school and
then i knew that i would need to teach
classes because we were always so lean
and elon insisted and rightfully so
on interviewing anyone that would work
for the school so you can imagine
you know he's essentially one standard
and that is like the ultimate standard
like could this person work for me at
spacex or
tesla or boring company or neurolink or
whatever else so
you know it's difficult to get more
teachers more administrators in the
school so we had to
you know always run it lean and i think
that's right and in doing so
you know brought in like just some
really talented people but for me it
always felt like
if you're gonna have someone like at
that time chris and many other educators
and people who are like coming at astra
hoping to see something different
that it was like imperative that i show
them that something that i had built or
someone at the school had built
that could convey a different type of
educational experience
like kind of the possibility of what it
could be and the thing that's just been
so exciting about building the company
of synthesis is to be able to see things
that i designed in illustrator
like pdfs like essentially like really
intricate
like board games or you know or
simulations that have just relied on
you know google sheets to see those
things brought to life through software
like that's the thing that to me is like
most powerful
is we would play this elaborate
simulation over eight weeks and then it
would come to an end never to be used
again
and now like that same simulation can be
condensed into a shorter amount of time
and you can play it
and like learn the lessons from it over
and over again and that's
like it just kind of blows my mind to be
honest absolutely
and honestly uh maybe introduce yourself
and kind of talk a little bit about
as you come for more of a traditional
teaching background kind of the issues
that you had seen with many young kids
who didn't have the ad astra experience
and kind of what was the frustrating
part for you on that front
yeah so i'm anna fabrega i'm a former
elementary school teacher
i left the classroom about a year and a
half ago um for the same reasons that
josh has been talking about and the
things that elon noticed that were wrong
with the system like i think a lot of
people are now aware
um that we're still following a very
outdated system
um and well my biggest concern was that
um i was very excited to teach kids
and challenge them creatively and and
teach them how to be innovative and how
to
really learn the skills that they're
going to be using in the real world
um and you know you quickly realize when
you're teaching that
you're not using or spending kids time
in the most meaningful ways like kids
are capable of doing so many things
and they're very hungry and they want to
learn um but we just
cram them with all this work that's very
meaningless and we're just
you know some for so many hours we're
with them in school and we're really not
training them for the kind of future
that that they want to live and the
kinds of jobs that they want to have
um in the future and they talk about
this so um
i i just grew very discontent and i
quickly realized that i was going to be
able you know i wasn't going to be able
to do a lot within this system
so i left and i turned to the internet
um and i started sort of writing online
and building my audience and connecting
with
different people in the alternative
education space that were
working on different learning
opportunities and things that look
different
and what i quickly noticed was that most
of the people that i spoke to that were
innovating
in education were really just making
slight iterations to the old system
right
they were either trying to make
classrooms more take enabled or they
would create an app
or something that they would claim that
it's more you know to help kids learn
but really they're more teacher enabled
tools and they're not really tools that
are helping kids learn
so the outcomes are pretty much the same
you're just sort of adding things
to um you know the same old structure
and to me
that's not really fixing the core
problem which is that kids don't
understand the purpose
of why they're going to school the
things that they're learning they're not
engaged and they're really not
being you know they're not doing
meaningful things in school and all this
innovation wasn't really fixing that um
until i spoke to
chrisman um when he was still working at
custodia and then he
started telling me about synthesis and
it sounded too good to be true
but when i joined one of their beta
testing sessions that's when i really
saw the magic um and you know the kids
were just engaged
in ways that had never seen kids you
know you know raving about their
learning in that way
um and i realized that the reason why it
was so effective was because of the way
that they had you know that josh has had
thought through how he wanted to create
this school right so when he he talks
about how when he was talking to elon
like they really instead of doing what
most of the people trying to innovate do
which is
okay what can we add let's you know
continue grabbing what's already been
done and making a little bit better they
were like no
let's just rethink education from first
principles which essentially means like
you know
going back to like the fundamental
truths what do we know
is true about how kids learn like really
focusing on that what do we know about
the kinds of jobs that they're going to
have in the future what kind of skills
can we help them develop since they're
young for the creator economy for like
all these things right so
they really focused on that and that's
why they created you know the learning
experiences that josh designs
i've never seen anything like that and
it's because they're
they're just designed um for the kids
and and thinking of like like josh
explains like with all these sprinkles
of complexity that he wants
the kids to be solving and it's it
really like you can see the relevance to
the real world and the kids can
understand why they're doing the things
that they're doing and that's just
really magical
um and that's what hooked me so i
decided to um join
and and we're building this um with the
kids right and with the feedback of the
families that we have and not really
like
looking at what other people are doing
or basing off the things that have
always been done right we just want to
do something
that you know that works so that's sort
of for sure
and so when i look at kind of the team
you guys have assembled it's a very
unique
uh kind of set of experiences of skill
sets chrisman maybe
describe a little bit just when you
think of the product
how exactly does the product work and
what is kind of the the child's
experience in the product right we heard
kind of
josh's perspective as to where the
original idea for
a synthesis-like course came from and an
experience in person
ana's explaining you know kind of what
the problem is but how does this
specific product work
yeah so you know the promise that we
make
to parents is you know we will we'll
make your child a world-class
problem solver right so the analogy i
use a lot is uh
is like i have my kids in jiu jitsu they
just they really like wrestling each
other the two boys
they go to jiu jitsu i know they're
they'll learn how to you know stand up
to bullying or you know something like
that
i can see them like building this skill
and it kind of compounds
over time um and i think you know when i
go back to like what i
what i witnessed at astra that's what
that's like what my
my feeling was like kids who go through
this
they will be world class at at solving
problems as a team which is the world's
most valuable skill
so that's kind of the promise that we
make you get your kid in synthesis
that's that's what's going to happen the
way we do it right now
is we're starting with like an
enrichment program so it's just uh it's
one hour a week sessions
they're led by a facilitator you've got
like 15
16 kids per group and
what they what they do is uh not to give
too much away for the first class we
would have been keeping this kind of a
secret but uh
hopefully the kids won't listen to this
um but what we do is we're just like say
hey
this is welcome to synthesis this is
unlike any experience you've had in
school or anything
education related what what you're going
to learn to do here is become a
world-class problem solver so you can
build
you know we want you to build cool
things we want you to make the world
better build flying cars build
jet packs you know give it give us clean
energy like dude
you're going to work your way up to
doing these kind of things and the way
you're going to do it
is the way the way it's going to be done
in the world is no one's going to be
able to really tell you the rules or
like how it works or tell you if you
have the right answer or even if there
is a right answer
so that's what we're going to do here
through these these problems we're gonna
give you
and then we'll just go they'll the hands
will go up and they'll be like
what are we gonna do exactly and we're
like you know we're they're not gonna
tell you that
and uh they'll ask a couple other
questions and we'll just say like you
know we're not gonna tell you and then
we'll
put them in breakout rooms they'll uh
they'll get their team there and they'll
have like a screen that like
lays out a problem and you know the
first ones kind of they look a lot like
video games
and they've kind of just got to discuss
like analyze strategize figure out you
know what they're what they're gonna do
and then uh and then the game starts and
it's just you know try to try to win
and then after the game we we do like a
debrief
so we we talk about you know what you've
learned what you figured out
what kind of course corrections you want
to make and then and then go back and do
it again
and uh you know the idea is that the
games get uh
sorry one sec
[Music]
um the idea is that the games get more
complex we're gonna have to do a little
edit there
um but the idea is like as you master
one level of the games they get more
complex so the games get more complex
uh and your competition levels up as
well so if you remember for like the
science fiction novel ender's game like
this is how they train kids to fend off
an alien invasion
because that competition and like
novelty
um even when you just keep doing that
you you develop like problem solving
skills
in general and the competition sharpens
you and just drives you to a higher
level
than you could get on your own um
so yeah that's the that's that's kind of
the core of it
josh explain a little bit why it's so
important to go through this experience
with uh kind of peers
uh or other uh kids why not just have it
as kind of a single player type
experience but but rather have it as a
multiplayer experience
yeah it's a great question just like
just having to
like to navigate the dynamics of a team
and i think
you know it's just i just i just came
from a class um at astronomer synthesis
and it's just so interesting like the
way that like roles are defined in a
team
like so the so one of the things that we
do you know there's
like the synthesis experience has you
know the cohort is broken into like you
know maybe four teams of four or five
teams of three or whatever that is
and those teams like will compete
against one another but it's not like
cut throat it's just like a way to kind
of like melt you know measure yourself
relative to one another
but then we do these cohort wide
challenges where you all work together
as a class and try to accomplish like a
specific
goal in this specific example they're
playing a game called art for all where
they're like
needing to curate like different works
of art to put them together by harmony
and
take them to different cities for
attendance and profit and all this all
this all these different dynamics
but what's so interesting when kids have
to collaborate is that
like you know by default some kids are
basically not speaking they don't feel
comfortable
participating in like a traditional way
especially in the zoom room and there
are others that de facto just sort of
assume responsibility they've not been
elected they just sort of decide that
they are
like they are the ones take control and
i just felt like in most collab like at
least my experience in school it's like
a group project was like a nightmare
because you were either the kid that was
like doing all the work or you're the
kid that was like
well i was the kid that was always doing
all the work and i resented the kids
that weren't doing any of it and
sometimes i guess as things got more
complicated some classes i was a kid i
didn't know how to participate
and felt like maybe lost and i think
we've all converted like
we can all we all remember like what
that feels like
so for me like there was just never a
moment for someone to be able to like
support me and becoming like a more
valuable member of a team to add like
real value
or to like kind of question the
assumptions that were made within the
group of like oh i'm in control because
like i'm loudest basically or i'm like
most aggressive or whatever that may be
so for me like the collaborative piece
was always like the greatest challenge
to unravel was like how to
make sure that your team operates
efficaciously so like
you know yeah there's like the context
of the game whether it's art or you're
like
you know deciding on like these like
fishing routes and like uh in like an
arctic where like the ice is melting
like there's all this complexity that
people think is just part of the game
design which it is
but the real complexity is like
navigating the dynamics of a team
and like knowing that like regardless of
whatever i designed that like that's
gonna actually be like the most
difficult part
and the part that's like most enduring
so for me the games you know we're not
i guess we are kind of like a game
studio at this point because we're just
creating so many because that generative
piece is so important to our like soul
like we must
always be learning lessons and
incorporating those into the next
experiences we design
but like you don't need a remarkably
elaborate game
to bring out like the collaborative
elements competitive
elements those like tough moments that
you can just like hit
pause or or look at the video in
reflection and say like hey like what's
going on here
like why why do you not think that you
accomplished your goal
like what what role did you play with in
this team and are you playing the same
role
over and over again is it because you
want to play that role or someone
assigned you that role or
you know you you just didn't feel like
there's any other role that you could
play
so it's just that that meta piece of
like really thinking about
how you feel in a team what you are
contributing or not able to contribute
and then like how can we remove those
barriers so that you can sort of be your
you know to flourish as as a as a
contributor so
it felt it's always felt like to me that
you can't do that over a poster project
or you can't do that over you know some
project where you have kids that are
totally different levels of ability
you need to create something that is
novel and complex that engages them in a
common mission but the games themselves
should be really welcoming so that
it's funny like really welcoming games
because i hate instructions
and yet ones that build in complexity so
that even like you know well not even
especially adults who were to play would
be sort of would marvel at
the fact that younger students can
handle this so well like i
confidently believe that our strongest
synthesis cohorts
would be nearly any collection of adults
in these games at least to start
and that is not necessarily because
they're you know
they have less experience or less wise
but because their team just
operates more effectively they
communicate better they're more honest
about what they know and what they don't
know
where all the ego of adults and all the
you know the jostling for positioning
um makes the team less effective so what
if getting
that experience now like what if they
could have that experience
in school like to learn how to be like
an unbelievable problem solver like
that's
kind of the promise of synthesis so
it's absolutely fascinating to me and
anna maybe you can talk a little bit
about
um you know when the kids go into those
breakout rooms what is the conversation
like like
are they um kind of as uh as josh has
alluded to here are they
able to uh communicate well are they
you know struggling with maybe concepts
they don't understand just
what has been your experience in those
breakout rooms as to the conversation
yeah so i actually want to mention two
things so first to answer your question
um one of the things that i find really
unique
about synthesis is the way that it helps
kids find
their unique voice and this is something
that you know as a teacher
and i taught in many different schools
and attended to many different schools
you don't see like there's little
opportunity for kids to really like
you know give their opinion or you know
share really what they're thinking or
question things
um because it's really not a safe
environment although we claim that they
are like not really like how
embarrassing is it to say the wrong
thing in front of all your peers or then
getting that mark down
but in synthesis what i've noticed is
that you know we really help kids
develop and find um their unique voice
because the simulations are set up in a
way that
students get to um you know experience
sometimes being the leader but sometimes
understand that they don't always have
to be the leader right
but they do need to understand how top
level decisions are made right
so kids in synthesis what you notice is
that they get to contribute to
consequential decision making
but in a way that feels authentic to
them right so sometimes they're leading
sometimes they're disagreeing sometimes
you know they're like josh was talking
about like the different roles
but really but you know you sometimes
see at the beginning
kids that are not you know they're not
used to
um speaking so much or having to sort of
like take the lead
um and then suddenly they see like oh my
gosh and i know i you know this is part
of this is expected for me like this is
how i'm gonna help my team win
and you see them come out of their shell
then you have the kids who are you know
very talkative and you can tell that
these are the kids that in you know the
school they're the ones like leading and
what josh was saying like sort of like
dominating the team
and so and here they start to learn you
know they start to take a step down and
be like sometimes my ideas are not the
best ideas
you know maybe i should listen to my
other teammates um
and see because they come up with you
know a better strategy
um so it has been fascinating especially
as kids you know you perhaps don't see
this in the first session
but as kids go from one session to the
other you start to see them evolve
whether it is taking a seat you know a
step back or sort of like jumping in
and that has been incredible and then
the other thing i wanted to mention
was um one of the most unique things
about synthesis that again i hadn't seen
anywhere in any other learning
experience is the way that
we engage students so a lot of the
problem in education is that we're going
through an engagement crisis
um you know kids you know teachers don't
even know what to do anymore to get kids
to pay attention and that's because
again the whole system is you know
designed in a way that
that prevents learning right um and
what ends up happening is that
traditionally teachers add points or
you know they give extreme sync rewards
or and they think that this is going to
work but it doesn't it may work in the
short term it doesn't really work in the
long term and the kids are really not
learning
but in synthesis and josh i would love
for you to talk um perhaps a little bit
more about this
um the way that we engage kids is by
actually
making things complex and making things
unpredictable
and pushing kids to a certain extent to
be vulnerable
in the simulations and what i mean by
that is um
like we understand that kids you know in
school a lot of what happens is we water
things down we make things
easier or more predictable to sort of
because it's more manageable right it's
easier to grade and it's easier we think
that you know kids are just kids
that they're two problems with that like
that's not the real world right our real
world is very complex and very
unpredictable so
we're sort of like doing a disservice by
sort of watering things down and making
them less complex but also
when you make things like that it
becomes boring right and what we've
noticed in synthesis is that kids
not only can handle complexity but they
crave it
so they actually yes at first they may
be a little bit thrown off when we put
them in the games and we're like figure
things out
or you know things get more challenging
but then that's sort of like what
what makes them want to come back right
and that brings down like
when i say we push them to be vulnerable
is because we put kids in the way they
don't have all the answers so
when they put their guard down they're
able to connect more with the different
kids that they're meeting from different
countries and all so it's just
really different right like you know a
lot of educators don't think that that's
sort of like the magic pill to make kids
like want to learn and want to come back
by making things challenging and complex
and unpredictable
um so i don't know if josh you wanted to
like talk about that but i just think
that's genius that's fascinating
and it works really well yeah i mean you
want you want kids to like
feel like you want to like to feel what
it's like to solve a
difficult problem you want to like feel
what it's like
to like experience scarcity right like
you scarcity and like whether it's on
the map or like understanding what that
is and
and understanding game theory not
because you read about it because you
like are living it
in the choices that you are making and i
think what
what on uh mentioned about like
in because of the scoring right and
scoring is important not because like
we're always looking for the high score
but because like you can see how you've
done relative to other teams
and the lesson that i love most is like
to help students understand that because
they won in this
instance does not mean that they had a
winning strategy over time
right and they're like all of these
things that i think the students are
needing to like at least
in this i see them unlearning and
learning in like a more like
authentic genuine way because they know
that yeah maybe like things kind of fell
their way but that strategy over time
will probably not be successful or
a strategy that is the dominant strategy
for that moment might not be the overall
dominant strategy and other teams will
see what they've done and emulated and
then they need to figure something else
out uh and then i think the final piece
which has been mentioned before is like
students as collaborators
there's just such arrogance sometimes in
education about like what you know what
i don't know we're gonna like put all
this stuff together and then just like
basically give it to kids and
synthesis came from my early days of
teaching fifth grade 33 kids in east las
vegas like during the recession
and i basically just felt like i can't
like sell this stuff to kids like i
can't like tell you that this worksheet
matters really
i can't really tell you that this is
gonna make a material difference in your
life
and it just i think then because i just
i identify as like
someone who like likes to create things
or like try to come up with solutions i
just started generating more and more of
what i would create
because at the very least even if it was
flawed it's like i've like put time and
effort into this and i like structured
the problems in such a way
that i think will be engaging and
enriching and like worthwhile basically
um and you know i there's nothing more
worthwhile
than giving students a meaningful
experience and then
giving them the space to reflect on that
experience and to talk about it make
sense of it because sense making
is the most important thing like making
sense of the world for all of us
is the most important thing we need
educational experiences that allow that
to happen
and that's like what synthesis is meant
to be
i am uh i'm drinking the kool-aid i
absolutely think that uh you guys are on
to something here
uh chrisman obviously the uh the kids
don't get to make these decisions right
in terms of uh they don't have credit
cards they're not uh going and signing
up
uh in most cases um there they may hear
about it from a friend but ultimately
the parent has to uh
to make the decision and so talk a
little bit about
um maybe the types of parents that seem
to be drawn to this versus the types of
parents who
who just you know aren't as bought into
the idea of
non-traditional education if you will uh
but then also what are the things that
parents care about or what are the
things that they're evaluating
um the uh the program on in terms of
once they actually do start to put their
kid through it uh are they expecting
overnight
you know for there to be improvement is
it something that they they kind of buy
into and they believe they need to be a
big part of do they just trust you
and the software and the program to be
successful just what have you seen from
the parent side
yeah yeah that's a great question let's
you know the number one thing that we
see
that the parents have in common is just
like dissatisfaction with the way
things are done like if if i say you
know school is broken or you know
it's it's completely school just
disconnected from the world like what
josh said
this worksheet is not gonna make any
difference in your life the parents
you know that that's the one thing like
every parent at synthesis has in common
is they they are not willing to just
kind of trust their
child's future to the school whether
it's public school or like an elite
private school there's something there's
something that's uh that they feel like
is missing
um within then then to get to the second
part of your question like how
i kind of like how involved are the
parents definitely it varies
we've started doing this thing now where
we run uh we run the simulations for the
parents it's probably like the best uh
the best kind of like marketing sales
technique we could do
because some parents like they're
skeptical right they hear like okay josh
built this school at spacex like it
sounds really great like games but like
are the kids actually learning are you
just playing video games like
i don't get it and that
like having them do one of the
simulations has like a 100
conversion rate right like they get in
there and they're just like baffled
and it's you know it's this completely
like complex thing like they they don't
get it and they and they start trying to
make sense of it with their group and
then
you know they they'll win or they'll
lose but they'll they'll
they will see kind of like the reality
of the experience like like what josh
said it's like there's
we are we are teaching like some
knowledge about the world like we teach
these like mental models like these
concepts that come up across
uh across domains right but
it's not it's not like you're reading it
out of a book like you're living it and
then we're giving you like
tools to make sense of your experience
and so like when parents experience that
they're like oh
wow so it's not everybody that uh
that's joined one of those sessions yet
right like some parents really want to
get involved they want to be talking to
their kids about it they want like
they want us to recommend books that
they can read to like you know apply to
the scenarios the kids are facing um
in their sessions and then some are just
like you know they let their kids do it
for like
an hour a week and they just kind of
completely trust it to us so there's no
real pattern there but
i would say the main you know the thing
everyone has in common is they're
they're just dissatisfied with school
primarily because of the
you know the idea that two things really
one it's irrelevant and two
you know the speed limit if you're like
bored or unchallenged at school like
they feel like since
this is you know we we've you know had a
lot of uh
interest from like the gifted community
because they want things that are just
going to push their kids as much as
possible
yeah it seems like there's a pretty
significant correlation between uh
you know hey school is uh boring or
uh monotonous in some sense also adults
uh in kind of a traditional corporate
america job may feel the same way
right and sure it's different
information it might be different
tasks but you could easily see if you
take somebody from that corporate
america job that
is very monotonous and boring in nature
and you put them into one of these
environments it essentially just works
mental muscles that they don't work on a
daily basis right and so
uh you could very quickly see where they
kind of wake up and say wow this is
different this is something that you
know i don't i don't even get
um as a professional and so of course i
want my child to have this and
um i've got to ask and any of the three
of you can answer but uh have you guys
put uh adults into the simulation with
kids and had uh
either the adults win or lose but but
has there been a
comparison yet adults lose every time
i've done it yeah it's a bit hard for
all the berkeley thing right
and i did it with i did it yeah we did
it at astronoma we had astronomer kids
play with berkeley engineering graduate
students and uh
it was humbling to the students for sure
through the the berkeley students that
is i mean just in that
you know there's that you're like
overwhelmed at the speed of it right
and it's like you know it's it's kind of
amazing like so design the games that
have like components of the fast and the
slow but when they're fast they're
really fast like you're managing four
different auction styles of different
works of art that are happening
simultaneously and have to decide
which of these works of art is most
harmonious with your collection which of
these works of art based on like their
market for the cities that you want to
go to makes
the most sense for your like overall
trajectory as a team
and if you are expecting kind of like a
you know all right we're getting in
teams we're going to just kind of
collaborate on this problem
you know we're going to talk through
which of these 20 items will help us
survive
you know our plane crash in the desert
is it the mirror or the parachute or you
know that kind of stuff
it's just a totally different world and
uh
it's you know it's just it's amazing
also to see yeah it's really cool it's
really cool also to see
students like the confidence right the
confidence of like i can work on this
like i can like
i can make headway on this challenge in
this problem and i'm not
like so concerned about winning i'm just
concerned about like refining
the choices that i'm making and like
becoming like a better decision maker
and then also like helping to understand
that like
i'm like measuring my own value within a
team is like
the decisions and things i'm adding like
how well are those things actually
turning out
um that that type of thing is i mean
that's what makes us so excited to
unleash
these students over time of synthesis
onto the world because
we all wish that we had more of that
time as kids if we i mean as adults it's
like there's nothing better than working
on like a highly functioning team
with people that are like committed and
dedicated to what they're working on
spacex's success is not i mean
everyone is committed to going to mars
right like that's why everyone is
aligned in that way
so um so yeah yeah what you just
reminded me of as you were talking about
kind of the speed
is uh i grew up on nintendo 64 and i
would play like the double 07 game and
basically it had the speed it had right
now it tossed was just the speed of
video games and then i remember watching
one of my younger brothers years later
play a
call of duty and literally it's like 10x
the speed
and i remember i picked up the uh the
the console sticks and i was just like
there's no way i could play this game
right like the speed at which he was
processing information etc and so
you know not quite the uh the
advantageous benefit of
of education but still that that speed
really does matter and so
i i guess you know anna and uh and
christian as you guys think about this
like
what is the hope in terms of what these
children end up
going and doing like is it a failure if
they end up just being a middle manager
at
you know accountant somewhere um is the
expectation that they're gonna go on to
be
entrepreneurs and engineers um how do
you guys just think about you know
this is a starting point obviously for a
child
from an education and kind of
professional sense uh if you look at it
that way like
what's the expectation of them uh as
they grow
yeah i think there's you know it's it's
important not to have such strict
expectations for what kids are gonna do
they're gonna
you know they're gonna hopefully find
find something to do that matches up
with their personality
but there there is like a certain sort
of skill in just getting getting what
you want out of life right it's it's
about solving problems
and you know primarily it's about you
know learning how to think
rigorously and learning how to
communicate and collaborate with other
people we think
with other people and it's
that's kind of like the base like the
idea here is
you know solving complex problems as a
team that is the world's most valuable
skill that's
that's what makes elon the wealthiest
man and we just
got him all these fans because people
realize that skill is what moves
civilization forward
as well and so to the extent that
there's some general ability to get
better at problem solving we want to
cultivate that
make your child as skilled there
as possible and then who knows what what
they're gonna do like they could start
an organic farm they could uh
you know they could they could build us
you know the spacesuit that uh that
people will be wearing on mars like
whatever that's gonna get to like
specific knowledge they're going to go
in their own
direction and you can't really influence
that but but the core idea is like there
is some skill
of being able to solve complex problems
with a team
and we want them to get as much of that
skill
as possible i always use the kind of uh
analogy like there aren't world class
musicians who start
in their 20s but that's you know when it
comes to like innovation that's people
mostly don't start on
anything like that until they're in
their 20s they're done with college like
what if you start kids thinking that way
at like age seven and they get this kind
of rigorous program from age seven to
fourteen
now they're at 14 they've got the base
that you know
very few 35 or 40 year olds have now
what are they going to do
they're going to build on top of that
and do things that we can't imagine
that's what i'm really excited about i
just i just want to see
so i do think these the kids i've seen
go through it for a length of time like
it
it like rewires the brain and if we can
get to that
at a certain scale like that would be
pretty amazing
absolutely yeah um just to add to that
um so we say that we're like training
kids to be better problem solvers and
decision makers and i think that the
the decision-making part it's such an
important component of what synthesis
does so
in you know life is all about making
decisions right you either make good
decisions or you make bad decisions um
and that's why we talk a lot about like
mental models which is like a way to
um help have this like frames of
reference for difficult moments and to
make better decisions and wiser
decisions
kids don't really learn this in school
right the decisions that kids make in
school are very
like school setting oriented and very
simple and just
you know not transferable to real life
so even if
you know we have all kinds of different
kids right and this is some of them
are going to go ahead and create amazing
things and those tend to be the ones
that are really obsessed with synthesis
and they go the extra mile and the
session finishes and they want to do the
intensives which is like this new thing
we're launching for kids that are really
into it
um and perhaps those are going to be
like the innovators and the ones who you
know create amazing things
but then we also have other kids that
are there um and they're benefiting from
learning
again these mental models these new ways
of thinking from having the opportunity
to again
like find their voice um play different
roles in learning
and what i've noticed um from from
talking to a few of the students
a few months ago was that they um
they're finding that learning can be
enjoyable right
um so many of them joined thinking okay
so this is a science class
or a space class some of them say
because they hear this from parents
others go okay
this is a game um but then by session
two or three they realize wait this
this seems like a game but this is not
like a video game like there's
definitely something here where i'm like
you know there's more than that and they
realize that they're learning but
they're learning in a fun way
um and i think that that's so powerful
because that's what kids have mostly
lost
in school settings in traditional school
settings so getting them excited
to learn um and and to play different
roles and again like
you know find what's their best role in
a team and all these things that's
really exciting even if they don't go
ahead and
you know turn into innovators in the
future right um
so that's something very special that
i've noticed for sure
josh you uh you've out of all of us
spent the most time with
elon musk what do you see in the
kind of teaching of the actual
curriculum
and in the games that most mimics kind
of what goes on at spacex
and the way that elon thinks
i just think you just need like really
flexible flexibly minded people
that are have like a great grounding and
like what like what is the problem
you're trying to solve
and what are you know what are like the
steps to get there and what are the
course corrections you're going to make
along the way
um as things are inevitably going to go
awry or going like different than you
know originally imagined so i think like
for me it's just
so many problems i feel like we give
students are linear like it's just
you know it's just inputs and then
outputs and then or it's like a teacher
in history who is
there at best doing the synthesizing of
reading much of primary source documents
and like reading a bunch of like
different authors and perspectives and
then kind of giving you
what amounts to some version of the
truth through their eyes or through you
know through their mouth literally
um for me it's like like i
we like purposely leave you know pieces
of the game unfinished right like we
like you could you know one of the
challenges in the game like art for all
is like when you're trying to
put together works of art that have
harmony how like what's the way that we
like
you know organize these works of art and
like there's like code that like
students can find that can like help
them better understand
how like you could do harmony really
well it's just like one way that you can
approach the problem so it's like
there's always that kind of this mystery
to synthesis because
ultimately like the student themselves
is responsible along with their team to
try to figure out how it works
and when you don't start with an
instruction manual or like some long
kind of like onboarding process and you
just throw them into it and say like
your goal here is just to figure out as
much as possible like how this works
and what's so interesting is like
regardless of how old the students are
the same things will happen like they
will have they will see
something and they will just assume that
that thing will just endlessly happen
right rather than trying to prove
something like that is demonstrably like
not true
they are just looking for evidence that
like things are going to go that way and
if they don't it's like oh that must be
like a glitch or something else
so i mean one of the things i think is
actually really unique too is like
rather than
spend like a year designing a simulation
like for some of our leading cohorts
they like our beta testing like we are
like working on this game together we
are making changes
like hourly and we are just like trying
to try new configurations and part of
that
is that students design their own maps
right they design their
own um decks of cards for the game like
art for all where they're putting
together
like you know collections of art so if
you really believe in students as
collaborators
i get back to your original question
like that every single person has a role
to play at spacex
like every single person has a role to
play at synthesis and that role
is like all in like sort of this big
high-minded idea that like
we need more efficacious and ethical
problem solvers and we're gonna give you
real experiences of doing that now
and uh and you as a student as a
nine-year-old
can design a map that will be used by
thousands of students
that will help them better understand
network effect or like you could put
together a collection of like
of art and put it into a deck that could
be used to help students like
truly figure out like what harmony is as
it relates to the game
which is like one of the most
complicated things to figure out so i
just love
when we think of things that are just
like preset structured linear
like then there's just that openness um
with like one really ambitious goal and
i feel like spacex and the other
companies are that way
um you know you're trying to like truly
change the world and you know whether or
not we get there or not
i think we're showing how you know time
can be spent in super meaningful ways
but it only can happen if students are
part of that process
yeah that makes a lot of sense um anna
if you were to talk to
a parent and ask you from a
kind of a teacher's perspective why
should they put their
child uh into the program or into uh the
synthesis
uh class well my my first answer is
um they're gonna be learning the things
that they're not learning
in school right um and and
you know guaranteed that their time is
being used in meaningful ways
and and it's it's interesting i speak to
lots of parents um
and and you know you have all kinds of
parents you have the parents that are
more of
a traditional mindset um and the first
thing that they ask you is like well how
do i know
what my kid is learning like where do i
see are there grades how can i
measure the progress and like this
questions you automatically
like you immediately know that the
parents coming from and you you can't
blame them right like that's how
they've been that's how they were
educated right but that doesn't really
matter here like what we you know what i
usually like
what we we tell parents is like to think
about where their kids are
at the beginning of synthesis right and
then to think about
how are they improving over time in the
way that they reason through problems
and how they synthesize concepts right
um and we tell them like you as a parent
are such an important part of this
um because you know we're evolving with
you right we're evolving
and we're preparing this learning
experiences that are so unique and so
different
that's hard to explain them in words
right and that's actually a good problem
to have right
because that means that we're not doing
anything like that's been created
already
um but it's it's really like having them
and i like how josh
explains how it's sort of like synthesis
is sort of like that multivitamin that's
missing in a lot of kids education
so although we are an enrichment program
now like really the
but by coming to this program and
joining this community that's really
what we call it because it is a
community it has like so many different
aspects to it it's not just like that
one hour course
i mean going through it over the weeks
and over the months and over the years
like your child just starts to think
differently and they start to make
decisions differently um and they sort
of consider things that that they
wouldn't otherwise consider
and and it's amazing because you again
you you
don't expect kids to be able to make
this decisions and analyze things the
way that they do
but the reason why we think that is
because we don't give them the
opportunities in school settings right
but here we're like we trust that we
trust that they can do it
we know that that they're going to be
able to rise to the occasion and they do
like they do they always end surprising
you so for parents that are like worried
like okay it's session three like
where's the learning it's like wait you
need to you know you need to be patient
and see the progress it's more like a
an overall way of thinking that that's
different and you you feel that shift in
the kids
who take it seriously and who keep
coming back and believe in what we're
doing
chrisman how do you think about uh the
proof points that uh
it's working and parents want this uh
i'm privy
uh to obviously all of the data but i
don't know what you want to share kind
of publicly
uh in terms of how it's going and why
you uh believe that parents want this
do you mean proof points in terms of
like what are the what are the kids
learning or proof points is like like
back up like hey some synthesis is gonna
work and there's gonna
there's there's a bit more work the
second the ladder
the ladder joshua josh already told us
that the kids are going to learn
anna confirmed it now uh now explain why
this is working as a business
uh yeah you know it goes like the
the first thing i i sort of thought
before we started that uh
you know this this sort of mysterious
story of like elon starting the secret
lab school at spacex
and and doing this you know as josh
mentioned
people from all over the world came to
that school i i hadn't really realized
when i went down to visit there but it
was there was like a
there was like a discord server with
like a couple thousand people on it that
were just dedicated to like
trying to dissect like what josh is
doing at the school and like spread
spread that to their schools so i knew
there was a kind of a tremendous
amount of energy behind doing something
different and and i knew the story
the backstory would capture people's
attention but i i always uh
josh and i always talked about this like
in the really early days uh
i heard seinfeld seinfeld still does
stand up right and people
another community was asking him like uh
you know isn't do people just laugh at
whatever you say because you're seinfeld
and he was like no you get one joke he's
like they will laugh at my first joke
and then if i'm not funny
i'll bomb just like any other comic and
so i thought like you know the backstory
would be like that's like our first joke
right like we get
we will get people give us a chance like
one time um and then and then that'll
wear off
um but yeah it's been i guess we
launched our first beta
uh test like in august and then
i i i don't know the number off topic i
think like 80 of those kids are like
still
still with us like six seven months
later um
and our since we launched the
subscription there you know retention is
like even
even better it's like 85 like 90 percent
are still with us after three months and
the ones that have canceled it's
primarily like they say like a
scheduling thing like they
some you know schedule change but they
want to come back um
so yeah it's been this uh you know we're
starting to see their friend referrals
like most of our customers now are
coming from referrals to people who
already
already are in it and that's despite it
being you know it's a fairly like high
price like premium
thing right now um which is my intention
we kind of
the growth has been sort of insane we've
kind of had to the way to limit the
growth is like start with a high price
point and uh just try to make like a
really great experience for those people
and then you know we'll eventually
create kind of like pricing tiers so we
can be accessible to more people because
we don't you know it's not
uh we we we want to reach every kid with
this right like i think
ultimately that's that's the goal is
like every child should be able to
experience some version of synthesis
think that that's like the way to really
change the world
um but yeah so so far like uh
yeah people seem to love it kids seem to
love it and uh
you know the parents are happy with the
changes gotta you gotta be careful with
uh the pricing
i always joke that college is the only
business i know where there's a line out
the door when they raise prices somehow
the line gets longer
uh and uh yeah i i i always laugh at
that one
awesome guys listen thank you guys so
much for doing this i i am
obviously a huge fan it is a no-brainer
pretty much everyone who i think listens
to this podcast they've heard me talk
about it before
education is broken and i think that
kind of the rote memorization
uh and frankly just the lack of
creativity
critical thinking and problem-solving
skills that are taught to children is a
massive problem so uh the work you guys
are doing is going right after that and
i highly suggest everyone
who's listening if you have a kid what
probably you know ages
six through like 13 14 years old
so we're we're admitting uh age eight
now is kind of like the
the low end so it's 8 to 14 right now
but if you're
you know six or seven then go ahead and
apply because we'll be opening up
you know cohorts for the younger kids
soon okay
so if you're in those age groups or i
have kids that are in that age group go
ahead and uh
go apply uh where people go just uh
synthesis dot
com dot synthesis.is dot is all right
i was gonna say if you guys got the dot
com i feel like that one would have been
pricey
that one would be pricey yeah awesome
well listen thank you guys so much for
taking the time to do this i hope that
everyone learned a lot from it
and uh hopefully people will go check
out synthesis
yeah thank you thank you so much thank
you